[Música]
buenas noches era un poco
como me gusta mucho moverme
que se pongan de pie los voy a mover
tantito para que rompan el hielo
rompemos el hielo y ya se animen por
aplausos no me gusta ok primero vamos a
tomar aire cuando inhalamos cruzamos los
brazos como si nada y cuando exhalamos
bajamos los brazos para empezar les
inhala
instaló fuerte
más partes listos
es algo que se les viene a la mente
cuando escuchan la palabra la educación
física
el deporte ejercicio fútbol además la
vertical cuando yo ya tenía muy definido
lo que quería hacer lo que quería
estudiar ya en la secundaria y en la
prepa todo el mundo me decía que quieres
estudiar la educación física eso se
estudia antes no se le da la importancia
ahora o que se le da la importancia que
se le tiene que dar a esta asignatura
realmente pero antes menos entonces los
maestros de educación física de arte se
convertía de maestros avienta balones y
en que se convertía la clase en fútbol
no tengo nada en contra del fútbol pero
siento que hay muchísimos más deportes
sobre el fútbol cuando entré a la
primaria mi maestro educación física era
muy bueno ahí empezó mi obsesión por ser
maestra educación física desde muy
pequeña mis papás nos hicieron un gran
regalo de vida a mi hermano ya mí nos
inculcaron el amor por el deporte
estamos en un club deportivo y ahí yo
veía a mi papá que entraba a practicar
box jugaba vásquez por corría mi mamá
también corría nadaba nosotros corríamos
nada vamos éramos muy felices
cuando entraste cuando con mi hermano mi
aventura empezó ahí desde que era muy
pequeña y estoy una foto con mi papá que
era se metía tanto mi papá en el deporte
que le da más mi coach el propio coach y
así seguimos durante 14 años ellos
invirtieron invirtieron tiempo dinero y
esfuerzo lo cual les estamos muy
agradecidos porque forjaron en nosotros
autoestima forjaron valores forjaron
disciplina cosas que hacer deporte
[Música]
cuando decidí entrar a educación física
me di cuenta de tres cosas la primera de
32 alumnos solo éramos 6 mujeres
ahí dije va a ser muy difícil de poder
enfrentar los retos porque pues todo
mundo me voltea a ver y me decía no tú
tienes que estar en preescolar tuve está
primaria donde hay muchas mujeres y no
yo quería estar en educación física
hasta la etapa laboral fue cuando fui
discriminada por ser mujer y por mi
estatura porque yo me ofrecí para dar
basquetbol a un grupo de niñas y los
papás y las niñas pues tenían la idea de
que el entrenador de básquetbol
tenía que ser alto y fuerte como técnico
de orden negro grandote como el negro de
watts y josh educación física no es lo
mismo que deporte va de la mano pero no
son lo mismo y no existe la materia de
lagartijas
educación física
según la real academia de la lengua es
un conjunto de disciplinas de ejercicios
encaminados a lograr el desarrollo y
perfección corporales ahí lo dice nos
vamos a enfocar los maestros en
habilidades generales no todas las
personas estamos hechas para hacer
deportistas
así sea el músico sea pintor sea
escritor el niño necesita actividad
física y necesita desarrollar
habilidades bueno el niño el adolescente
y el adulto porque tenemos la idea de
que nada la educación física nada más es
alta para la edad escolar y no las
personas mayores también necesitan
educación física esto va a mejorar su
calidad de vida el deporte
es una actividad física ejercida como
juego o competición según la academia
cuya práctica supone entrenamiento y
sujeción a normas aquí se va a enfocar
solamente en una habilidad en la
habilidad que el deporte necesita por
eso les digo que no todos estamos hechos
para eso
no todos yo tengo un hijo de 13 años mi
hijo aunque no lo parezca
pero mi hijo es anti deportes totalmente
la verdad que desde que estaba chiquito
pues yo me esperaba para que le
practicara algo lo mediato o lo metía la
canción lo metí a tal cuando lo mete y
el lloraba y lloraba y lloraba cada que
íbamos a un entrenamiento y yo que
lloraba más de la preparación como un
hijo mío no va a ser deportista
sin embargo fue creciendo y fuimos
viendo que el resulta lento es el dibujo
talentoso para eso para la música pues
les digo artista yo puedo apoyar su
talento como mis papás apoyaron el miedo
pero no puedo permitir que mi hijo se
vuelva una persona sedentaria esos ya
muy diferente él necesita educación
física para no convertirse en alguien
sedentario y en tener enfermedades a
largo plazo están muriendo la gente por
obesidad y no nos damos cuenta aquí
según la unicef méxico es el primer
lugar con niños obesos y somos en
segundo lugar con las 18 besos entonces
todos necesitamos movernos brincar
saltar correr aunque no nos guste el
deporte necesitamos hacer algo y
finalmente esta frase de obra finalmente
me di cuenta de que está agradecida a mi
cuerpo era la clave para darme más amor
a mí misma
lo dice todo y fue cuando me gustó de
verdad lo que hago ahorita amo lo que
hago porque eso se lo transmito de mis
niños y lo transmito a las personas con
las que convivimos en educación física
en movimiento y deporte es felicidad eso
no me queda la menor duda pues con ellos
me identifico porque a pesar de las
diferencias
natural de géneros tuve que aprender a
hacer como ellos animarme como ellos
para poder sobrevivir en un mundo donde
predominan los hombres
es todo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]